hello and welcome to real-time AI bring
together dataflow tons of fluid standard
and cloudy hi my name is Sergei cycle
ANCA and I'm a product manager in the
Google cloud I wanted to start with a
motivating example recently worked with
a public safety agency which processes
tens of gigabytes of security logs per
day but not only a few thousand of these
logs are of high importance to them the
current processes for analysis and
finding these important logs the based
on heuristics and manual interactions
which couldn't scale to the growing
volume of logs so this agency engaged
with Google to process life-skill
datasets and wanted to build a
unsupervised solution to identify logs
review them and label them another
example who worked with the national
telecom which key is the critical mobile
traffic for a nation thus telecom needed
to address security vulnerability and
model threats and their current
techniques which were based on
traditional signature-based patterns
with insufficient they just couldn't be
updated fast enough so thus telecom
wanted to analyze sender and receiver
traffic and find the normal is in the
traffic and act on them the common
factors to these examples what is common
to them is that there's a large number
of events that is produced by a global
user base which creates billions and
billions of interactions when they use
these systems another important common
characteristic or factor is that our
customers want to react to these events
in near human ecology with mere human
intelligence and apply a high
intelligence than just counting numbers
for creating and calculating statistics
and lastly our users want to react to
events in near real-time
this is best visualized by the following
graphic businesses realized the highest
value from events when they act within a
time type time window
after the event creation another
opportunity to extract value from events
is by storing these teaming events in
data warehouses in doing analytics on
them in between isn't much value to
extract because data is stale or is
difficult to access and not in a data
warehouse which means it's not very
available across our customers we see
two types of common needs
recommendations and anomaly and pattern
detection recommendations are about
analyzing customer market signals to
present compelling offers and customize
content for example in the retail
industry you could create upsell offers
for your cards in the media industry you
could select the next video or song to
show to a customer in the financial
industry you could suggest a new
insurance offer and in the telecom
understeer you could create a hardware
offer or a service upsell cross-sell for
normal ease and pattern detection here
is what customers want to do is exha
mining examining streams of data to
identify data points which are outside
of the norm in the financial industry
for example you could detect insider
trading in retail you could find account
theft or credit card fraud in the
cybersecurity industry as we've seen in
our motivating example you could do a
denial of service attack prevention and
in health care you could do patient
monitoring and so if we want to take
these use cases if we want to act on
them to drive behavior and not just act
and discover things after the fact when
it's too late we need to use machine
learning and streaming analytics
technologies and this is what real-time
AI is about it's the difference between
preventing fraud and just discovering
fraud it's the difference between
driving more sales in shopping carts
versus seeing cards being abandoned when
customers move away from from them
machine learning together with streaming
analytics and the global event network
allows us to do real-time
the Google cloud offers a comprehensive
set of tools for model training and
inference be clear for example allows
you to do model training and predictions
right inside of your data warehouse
outside of the queer GCP has the Google
cloud platform cloud platform entenza
Flo extended Cody a platform offers
training inference and many specialized
services for video image text processing
and other types of unstructured data
processing tensorflow extended is a
platform for production use of machine
learning and it's centered around tons
of flow but is available not just on the
Google cloud what is common to all these
machine learning options is the solid
integration of data flow as the data
processor for example for bigquery you
can use steaming data flow to onboard
data into bigquery and then pre-process
it before it lands there once the data
is in bigquery you can train your models
using BQ ml which is a variant of sequel
and export the Train models and use them
inside of dataflow for steaming
predictions for the cloud di platform
beautifully integrates with cube flow
which is the orchestrator of machine
learning pipelines so the iPod from also
uses data flow internally to do model
training on CPUs or GPUs for tensorflow
extended data flow in Abel's all large
scale data processing both for feature
pre-processing as well as for model
improvement we can also bring streaming
amounts in the steaming inference
remember our motivating example with the
Public Safety Agency but we worked with
this agency and created a solution that
is based on a time series
anomaly detection solution and is
powered by data flow and tons of flow
extended this solution uses LS TM
encoder
Dakotah pattern it reduce the number of
logs that needed to be monitored
manually from billions per day to just a
few thousand per day which is doable for
for their analytical workforce this
solution is now available on the cloud
Google comm data flow in the real-time
AI section the solution consists of
three steps in the pre-processing step
we can word log data to a time series TF
record formatted data set and we store
it in cloud storage once data lands in
cloud storage we begin the model
training step now for which we use the
cloud AI platform training API this is
where the encoder/decoder
l STM model gets created and stored in
the cloud storage again a parallel data
flow pipeline is running and consumes
this LST M model and then the scores
each incoming theta record creates both
a reconstructed in actual time series
compares the two and Flags differences
in anomalies the output is again stored
in cloud storage in our second
motivating example we also developed a
anomaly detection solution which
processes steaming events caller records
for this telecom and the processing is
happening in data flow and the online
inference is also happening inside of
data flow we use bigquery ml to Train a
key means cluster model and we also use
cloud dlp to de-identify and anonymize
network traffic records before they are
being used for training
once the be kml model is trained it gets
deployed into steam in data flow and
it's used for detecting anomalies in
real-time this solution is also
available on our website
cloud at google.com slash data flow
real-time
AI
here's a graph that represents how
normally gets detected using a k-means
clustering the solution finds outliers
by measuring the distance between them
and the Centers of the customs outliers
that have a distance of more than three
standard deviations of the cluster are
considered anomalous this solution is
also structured into three steps the
feature pre-processing step the model
training step and the anomaly detection
step in the future pre-processing step
theta flu is reading data from pub/sub
the kaga records and is using called GOP
to anonymize the incoming records all
call detail records and on in an
anonymized form a stored in bigquery and
we use bigquery ml to train a model that
creates a k-means cluster model this
model is then used in a parallel data
flow pipeline which reads the same call
detail records and scores them against
the model the anomalies that are found
are outputted into a buff sub for
further action the solution is available
on our website under the real-time a
section
feel free to discover and customize in
addition to the two existing solutions
that I just covered today the announcing
new components and new solutions we
catered recently new Apache beam
components we call them transforms that
integrate data flow better with cloud
platform these components are for video
analysis for image analysis text
analysis GOP and many other areas we
also create at ATF X component that can
be embedded into beam pipelines for
steaming predictions either on locally
loaded models or on remote models and
the API stays the same in addition to
the new components we are also releasing
today five new solutions for anomaly and
pattern deduction
can use these solutions as is you can
customize them or you can use them as
examples for the components that we
developed and provided for you let's see
what these solutions do these solutions
allow you to do three types of things
pattern detection anomaly detection and
predictive forecasting for example for
pattern detection you can find objects
where they're not supposed to be you can
use our solutions to anonymize and D
identify aberrational data a very common
need by users you can also use our
solutions to reduce shrinkage by
tracking packages door-to-door those are
just a few examples of the application
of our solutions for anomaly detection
in the telecom case you can find malware
by detecting anomalies in traffic
between senders and recipients for
financial services you can find
anomalies in currency pair and stock
trades you can also find fraudulent
transactions or money transfers in an
account for predictive forecasting you
can use our solutions for equipment
maintenance for example you can forecast
the probability of equipment failure
based on images and then send
technicians to address those forecasted
failure conditions let's look at our
first solution the solution allows you
to detect patterns in video clips and
here we integrated with the cloud video
intelligence API for object recognition
as data gets as video clips get stored
in cloud storage we get a notification
about these clips through pops up into
data flow and the clips get uploaded
into data flow and processed through the
video intelligence API once we know what
objects are inside of video clips they
can be cars cats persons or moving
objects the labeling information is
stored together with the clip metadata
either
in the bigquery or into Babson data flow
here is used for several things for
example we do smart clip partitioning so
that a one minute long clip gets
processed in just a few seconds the LFO
can also do a smart batching of video
clips to fully exhaust your available
quota and increase your throw bot you
can use file inputs as well as three
Alpine inputs meaning pub/sub messages
to indicate that a new clip is available
and information information about labels
can be stored in data warehouses in file
systems or in messaging buses this
solution as the previous two solutions
are is available on our website and can
be reviewed in the real-time AI section
on the data flow page in our second
solution second new solution we allowed
you to project equipment failure by
using and analyzing images of this
equipment here we integrated with the
cloud vision API and we looked for
pattern patterns in images as data and
as images get uploaded to cloud storage
notifications are being sent to dataflow
dataflow reacts to the availability of
new images and calls the cloud vision
API and once we have the labels and
classifications of objects inside of
images we store this information in
bigquery we can use this solution today
as is or you can customize and change
the pipeline logic because in addition
to the solutions we also gave you the
standardized Apache beam
transforms which you can integrate in
any kind of pipeline you have today you
can also save costs through data flows
smart batching approach data flow is
using its State Empire API to convert a
steam of image files into micro batches
and cause-cause the API the cultivation
API efficiently and fully exhaust the
quota in the capacity that you have
in our next solution we allowed
customers to anonymize and D identify
PII data and here we integrated with
cloud DLP which is a Google cloud
service for anonymizing private PII data
the service also provides recognization
T identification and other services data
flow here is is used to maximize the
throughput of the cloud dlp API again we
are using the data flow state and timer
capabilities to smartly batch together
calls to the car DLP API and use your
resources efficiently you can use file
sources you can use real time sources
and data clean data can be stored in a
variety of outputs including bigquery
pub/sub cloud storage and other things
this solution as many others is
available on our website please navigate
to the data phobia page and review the
real-time AI section in our next
solution we implemented and integrated
with Klaudia a prediction API to find
anomalies in financial transactions this
integration is not just specific to the
financial services industry you can use
this pattern across many many industries
our particular model to find anomalies
is based on boosted trees so it gives
you another pattern to to put into your
toolbox of anomaly detection solution
solutions the model was trained in the
called AI training API and deployed and
hosted into the cloud a I'd prediction
API data flow as in many other cases is
used to optimize performance and
throughput at micro bashes calls to
cloud the I and it increases the
throughput of your system in our last
solution they are using yet another
approach for anomaly detection
here we integrated with tensor forex
standard and use the run inference
transform that was recently developed
and at least this transform allows you
to have your models hosted both inside
of data flow as well as remotely in
cloud the eye prediction before we use
prediction prediction API data actually
needs to be pre-processed and here's
here's where data flows strengths are
coming to to play data gap gets on where
the draw data from external data
providers gets on board through pops up
and it gets aggregated in data flow
specifically we divide row trades into
time windows and run a variety of
statistics on them for example calculate
means kendall statistics as well as the
RSI stats which stands for relative
strength index and is an indicator of of
movement of data the people the P
process data records
gets get transformed into TF example
records and stored and cloud storage
from where we pick up yet another key FX
pipeline and use cloudy eye training to
create the model for the actual anomaly
detection this model is also based on L
STM encoder/decoder approach it's
trained and clouded ai training and you
can deploy it in two places you can
deploy it either in data for itself on
the data for workers for local inference
which reduces latency or you can deploy
this model in cloudy I prediction API
for remote inference the interface to
these calls is always the same this is
where you can use our newly developed
EFX around inference transform this
solution as many others is available on
the data flow page under the real-time
AI section just do is create a data flow
does to pre-process
draw stock trades before they get used
in the training of the anomaly detection
model take
look at this graph else wrong event
events representing trades enter the the
pipeline we divide them into time and
those represented by accumulators on
this graph and we calculate rolling
window statistics on them for example we
calculate the mean of these ten vendors
and we calculate dependent and another
statistics for example the RSI index
again RSI stands for relative strength
in this with this I would like to a prop
up my session and just go through the
main points of the of the session as
you've seen you can use data flow today
for data processing with a variety of
machine learning technologies including
bigquery ml cloud a I and tons of flow
extended we've recently launched new
Apache being transform transforms for
video images DLP and text processing we
also released a new T effects well
transform that integrates with beam for
generalized streaming predictions and be
launched and released five new solutions
for anomaly detection and pattern
recognition if you would like to learn
more please go to cloud.google.com slash
data flow and find the real-time AI
section thank you for watching this
session I hope you found it informative
till next time